cheechoo reçoit omar sy pour un
entretien exceptionnel face à un écran
et quatre caméras l'acteur se confie
sans détour sans tabou at home à pied
trois châssis nous sommes en 2019 9075
kilomètres de los angeles 10,6 km de
châtelet les halles 5208 km de dakar et
du sénégal et à quelques centimètres
seulement d'omar sy passer par tous ces
lieux un acteur qui nous vient de loin
bonjour merci bienvenue dans chit chat
avec nous vous serez face à un écran nos
caméras et surtout vos images celles de
votre vie une vie de cinéma mais pas que
près oui je suis prêt je suis prêt écran
aujourd'hui vous venez nous parler d'un
film humaniste et solaire et ce film
c'est yao yao c'est un jeune garçon 13
ans qui traverse le sénégal en solitaire
pour rencontrer son idole seydou tall un
acteur français venu promouvoir son
dernier livre
yao c'est l'histoire d'une rencontre
c'est l'histoire d'un voyage c'est
l'histoire d'un retour aux racines
bien voiture est tombée en panne parce
que l'été vieille usées là où tu es
vraiment naïf c'est là que tout commence
pour coter jamais venu au sénégal
c'est pas les histoires comme ça ça se
voit tout de suite que le chemin de
hausse est continue à guider tepa
mais est-ce que vous pouvez nous
expliquer à quel point ce film est
important pour vous déjà parce qu'il est
beau c'est un beau film
et puis non il parle il parle du sénégal
sénégal c'est le pays de mon père
il parle de la paternité il parle de la
transmission il parle d'identité il
parle de spiritualité et tout ça ça me
parle énormément je suis très content
que ce film existe un jour vous avez
fait ce voyage avec votre père au
sénégal est ce que ça a changé quelque
chose pour vous ça a tout changé
wesh parti au sénégal avec mon père à
l'âge de 19 ans c'était pas la première
fois mais c'était la première fois que
j'étais seule avec mon père je veux une
fratrie de sept
donc c'est très compliqué de passer du
temps en tête à tête avec nos parents et
là j'étais dans une voiture où allah qui
roulait comme ça et j'ai eu tout ce
trajet là deux jours de voiture avec mon
père on a pu discuter et ça a tout
changé justement parce que c'était plus
précis sur l'histoire de mon père son
identité donc du coup ça m'a permis à
près de trouver mieux moi et à 19 ans
c'était le bon moment
donc ouais ça a changé beaucoup de
choses et d'ailleurs ce film c'est pas
mon histoire mais justement ce voyage là
qui m'a qui m'a transformé c'est un
petit parallèle avec ce voyage qui
transforme qui transforme le personnage
omar sy c'est qui c'est quoi c'est ça
vous êtes né en 1978 dans le 78 on vous
dit garçon calme et tranquille vous
aimez bien tupac
oui j'aime bien tout parc mais aussi
jean jacques goldman
[Musique]
oui voilà ça c'est tout moi vous avez
connu jamel debbouze à 6 ans ils
travaillaient bien à l'école
6 1 ça nous énerver tous c'était comme
pour nous dire je crois comme vous je
traîne avec nous parce que j'aime bien
l'ambiance mais j'ai mon plan vous vivez
dans une cité qu'on appelle la cité de
la joie et à 18 ans vous voyez patron
d'une entreprise de climatisation que je
pars comment je me suis retrouvé à faire
des frigos voir je crois que né en 1998
la vie change jamais elle vous emmène
sur radio nova puis canal+ et un jour on
vous donne cette carte carte magique lé
gaza ça c'était un passeport incroyable
donc là j'ai 20 ans et donc je suis à
cannes pendant le festival
et avec cette carte gérante partout je
rentre partout les choses sont gratuites
enfin je change de vie quoi là où à
cette époque-là ce très compliqué de
rentrer en boîte de nuit même quand tu
payes et que tu es bien habillé là
j'étais en basket en sweat à capuche et
j'avais ce truc là autour du cou j'étais
le roi du monde et c'est là aussi où je
rencontre fred et je découvre ce qui va
devenir ma vie après elle ne rompt pas
ça la suite vous aimez michael jackson
et le foie gras poêlé comment vous savez
pour le foie gras poêlé c'est incroyable
ça quand même
vous aimez aussi cette chanson vous
écrivez encore des cartes postales vous
détestez les tripes
votre première émotion cinéma a été pour
bambi vous êtes capable de danser sur
tout et peut-être même sur ça
[Musique]
note 6 aubance part on chante ses coûts
généralement en voiture ça et dans les
films qui vous inspire
il y à ça
ouais ouais j'aime beaucoup alors bon
beewi comme un peu tout le monde je
crois de mon époque que c'est c'est
violent bambine ans quand même parce que
c'est risque ben c'est très triste
comment ce camp il cherche sa mère
l'agent cause de l'art l'agent passer
des frissons
ils servent sa mère vers la butte est
quand même bon c'était horrible c'est
horrible mais après rocky rocky
c'est la première vhs que j'ai eu je
crois y avait une vhs de bruce lee ont
péri nous avait ramené et rocky mais
c'est qu'est l'histoire incroyable d'un
mec était un peu comme nous en fait qu
avait rien du tout et en lâchant rien en
se battant comme un dingue
il arrive au sommet donc c'est et amp c
est en fait un super film avec la
musique incroyable donc ouais moi c'est
moi j'ai pas honte de dire que c'est un
de mes films préférés
kylie ann m bape et qui viennent mba
paix à 20 ans il a fait la une du times
en octobre il vient de banlieue
parisienne comme vous ai déjà eu de
cesse de vouloir lire à mener est ce que
c'est chiant quand on vient dans lieu
d'être toujours ramené à la banlieue
dans ces patients ce qui est plus
inquiétant c'est pour ceux qui ne
peuvent pas faire qui peuvent qui
peuvent pas s'empêcher de lui parler de
ça lui c'est pas un problème pour lui
mais la question que c'est plus pourquoi
les gens besoin de le ramener à ça
pourquoi les gens ne laisse pas à
grandir et je ne parle pas de là où il
est aujourd'hui
parce que parce que les gens sont très
curieux de la banlieue on se pose
beaucoup de questions sur la banlieue
mais en fait on n'a pas les bonnes
réponses parce qu'on pose pas la
question aux bonnes personnes mais en
tout cas c'est c'est génial qu'un mec de
bondy fasse la couverture du time ce
même moi je le dis ça et c'est
intéressant de voir que ça se fait mais
maintenant il faut juste se demander
pourquoi c'est exceptionnel ce à cette
question là qu'il faut répondre et vous
avez une réponse non je n'ai pas sinon
je serais pas là je serai président de
la république mon pote
omar sy en trois mots en trois mots
c'est une personne
affectueuse grand intouchable solaire
personnalité chaleureuse que je veux
c'est l'iran c'est humain et travail est
beau ouais extrêmement sympathique
cratère neil est ce qui manque quelque
chose ne se croit pas c'est déjà très
bien tout ça c'est très bien tout ça
c'est déjà très bien que ce soit eux qui
le disent en plus moi j'aime pas je ne
sais pas si c'est à moi de me décrire ce
n'est pas le faire bon eh ben nous on
s'en charge
madonna barack obama steven spielberg
ont un point commun ils ont vu
intouchable mais il n'ya pas que savoir
c'est vrai tu as aimé merci beaucoup
merci papa sophie même si je te vois pas
des années jetant du monde et c'était un
jour important cette projection
intouchable devant vos parents bien sûr
bien sûr mais en plus y avait pas que
mes parents l'arna skywest donc c'est le
cinéma le plus proche de trappes
donc j'avais aussi beaucoup d'amis dans
la salle j'avais tous mes frères et
soeurs
ouais c'était un moment important et je
me rendais pas compte en plus au moment
où ça se passe et que ça allait être un
truc aussi grand et puis en plus là dans
ces images là où on voit on voit très
bien le fonctionnement de mes parents
mon père qui dit qu'il a aimée sans rien
dire et ma mère toujours plein en plein
grand quoi donc
oh non lancé je suis un peu ému même de
revoir ces images là même si je les
connais par coeur mais voilà ça c'est
ccc mes parents là la chaleur des
parents et et tout le monde autour auger
j'ai beaucoup de chance d'avoir vécu est
quelque chose comme ça et en plus assez
tôt en fait dans ma carrière donc
c'était cool
vous dites sans rien dire est ce que le
silence est quelque chose d'important
pour vous encore plus aujourd'hui
ouais bien sûr et forcément
grâce ou à cause de lui mais voilà
repasser le truc il ne dit pas qu'il est
mais je le sais voilà et wei s'exprime
beaucoup par le silence et ewz est
aujourd'hui moi je me sers aussi des
fosses de ça pour m'exprimer
ça veut dire quelque chose de silence on
revient sur le succès d'intouchable
intouchable c'est une affiche ses douze
affiches dont trois affiches attendait
non intouchable c'est toutes ces
affiches
[Musique]
19 millions d'entrées en france 32
millions d'entrées dans le monde et 51
millions en tout et voilà ce que ça
donne et mais en fait vous sentez rien
du tout la même
c'est le cas des boutons bisogno vous
préférez dans quelle langue
je sais pas en fait vous avez combien de
minutes de ça s'il vous plaît faites moi
un cadeau en partant je voudrais
repartis avec un truc comme ça j'adore
ça
j'adore ça ça c'est encore un cadeau du
film ce film il n'a pas arrêté de nous
faire des cadeaux de nous faire des
surprises
c'est génial c'est génial allez on
enchaîne un jour vous êtes un petit
point ce point là et vous êtes dans la
rue vous regardez autour de vous et vous
avancez vous entrez dans un bâtiment un
grand bâtiment et vous marchez vous
monter des escaliers et vous entrez dans
une pièce là vous vous asseyez dans un
siège et vous entendez ça le gagnant est
omar sy je vais tout de suite comme ça
ça sera fait remercier mes parents mes
frères et soeurs à leur dire que je les
aime voilà j'espère qu'ils sont fiers de
moi
eric ollivier merci beaucoup merci pour
tout merci pour la confiance que vous me
donnez depuis des années et voilà il ya
mes enfants qui me regardent voilà donc
allez vous coucher je vous aime les
enfants ça c'est pour vous merci de me
laisser vivre tout ça est une personne
qui me laisse vivre tout ça et qu ils
m'encouragent depuis très très longtemps
c'est ma femme hélène donc je t'aime mon
amour
voilà donc je vais partir mais juste
[Musique]
là c'est comme si je peux vivre
[Applaudissements]
si bien content c'est fait je m'en fous
mais si comme un dingue
merci beaucoup merci à tous et je prends
je crois un truc très très gros qui est
très difficile à à gérer donc ce qui ce
qui se passe après ouais c'est comme si
j'étais complètement bourré que des gens
de poortere je crois après c'est énorme
la fiac ce n'était pas du tout préparé à
ça mais on revient encore à la magie de
ce film là c'est que voilà aussi ce
qu'il a apporté ce film là c'est que ce
césar là c'est quelque chose de concret
que j'ai dans la main cassée visible pas
ce qui brille et du coup c'était concret
pour moi ce métier c'est tellement gros
que défense demande si c'est vrai et
après le césar il y avait il y avait un
truc que je pouvais faire c'est quand je
me disais mais est ce que tout ça c'est
vrai en fait
et j'allais voir le césar je peux aller
voir le césar il touché il existe et
donc il va il est important c'est césar
pour moi en tout cas
après intouchable vous avez entamé une
carrière à hollywood on vous regarde à
l'avant-première de jurassic world en
2015 non s'arrête deux secondes je suis
dans ce film-là jurassique world
on est à paris c'est la première
mondiale voilà s'il vous plaît donnez
moi ça que moi ça c'est le moment
mais moi ça merci quand même aux médias
bordel de merde rendez vous compte là
c'est vrai dans pêche à paris c'est la
première du veau de nos mondes le monde
teal'c lundi ici un premier neuf et cela
faut que ça se reproduise merci merci
beaucoup
ouais là j'étais heureux là bas j'étais
heureux et je suis encore heureux quand
je vois ça je suis heureux quand je vois
ça aussi assez fou et ouais c'était
exceptionnel de là d'où je viens je me
rappelle du moment où le poids le
premier la première fois que j'ai vu
geraci que jurassic park où j'étais et
puis est là quoi
c'est dingue c'est dingue le trajet que
c'est
et quelle expérience aussi vous avez une
drôle d'histoire avec les petit
moustachu
vous avez dit un jour que vous aviez
peur qu'il y en est un qui viennent
sonner chez vous pour vous dire que tout
ça c'était un rêve
c'était une erreur ah oui comme ça
oui oui bien sûr comme ça c'est vrai que
les huissiers qui venaient à la maison
il y en avait beaucoup à moustache
donc c'est peut-être lié et pourquoi
vous l'imaginez avec une moustache du
quotidien alors là je là il faut que
j'aille voir un médecin pour ça c'est
pas voir un spécialiste j'en ai aucune
idée
je rappelle que vous êtes à la fiche de
yao un film de philippe godeau qui
sortira le 23 janvier cet esat
j'ai l'impression qu'avec ce film j'ai
j'ai un peu j'ai un peu travaillé sur ma
pudeur et mon métier d'acteur parce que
c'est pas vraiment compatibles et là
j'étais un peu moins pudiques que
d'habitude dans les sujets qu'on aborde
et dans ma manière de jouer ce
personnage et et tout ce que ça raconte
toutes les valeurs que ça sur la
transmission sur la spiritualité sur sur
l'affiliation en fait il ya plein de
choses là dedans qui sont importantes
pour moi et qui en plus j'ai
l'impression qu'ils sont importantes en
ce moment est ce que vous vous ferez
comme avec votre père ce voyage au
sénégal avec vos enfants bien sûr bien
sûr mais mais j'attends le bon moment
j'espère que j'aurai l'intuition aussi
aiguisé que celle de mon père et de le
faire vraiment au moment où ça va où ça
va vraiment compté quoi mais ils sont
déjà allés au sénégal mes enfants mes
mais un tête à tête à travers le pays je
le ferai avec chacun mais je pense que à
chacun son moment il faudra être
attentif pour choisir le bon moment
merci beaucoup merci
merci à vous
[Musique]
vous pouvez me parler là parce que je me
sens seule